everything is taking a major hit and
crypto took a bad hit and it's been
getting beaten up pretty bad even
bitcoin's getting beaten up
but
this is the market this is this is the
ship sinking
you look at the graph of the of
inflation i mean it's it's 8.2 it's 8.4
it's 8.6 worse than it's ever been since
world war ii consumer prices are
skyrocketing
yo
i hope you guys are ready for august
but you know i'll say this while the
regular people are suffering under this
big massive financial institutions are
getting free cash from the federal
reserve and to the tune of how much we
don't even know trillions trillions of
dollars probably it's off the books off
the books they're buying up property
some of these big firms they're buying
houses people they're they're offering
30 premiums because the money doesn't
matter the number amount doesn't matter
what matters is they get the land from
you dude this is what i'm has been
bothering me if if my crypto value goes
down 100 or 90
and then but they get all the funny
money from the federal reserve they can
just buy it up with funny money bro i've
been saying this
this is
unconscionable i don't think these
sorry to interrupt you no no i i was
saying this a month or so ago probably
not as eloquently as i could have
because i'm not like a crypto expert
but i want to point out to people that
this the federal centralized banking
system that allows them to effectively
expand the money supply at on a whim
they can just buy crypto from people
they can buy as much as they want and
control the market
engineer because they're they are you
know behind the exchanges a lot of the
crypto exchanges are actually not
working on behalf of the customers
because they have all the data that can
kind of predict what is going to happen
they know where all the leverage points
are
so uh they're batting against customers
yeah but i don't wanna i don't wanna get
ripped too much in the crypto stuff the
point is the entirety of the market
like right now the market's dropping
ultra wealthy people are like oh
fantastic
because here's how it goes it goes it
goes this way every time you go back
throughout history market drops poor
people panic they sell as much as they
can because i got to buy bread rich
people who don't have to worry about it
buy up all this property and assets for
pennies in the dollar then the market
goes back up and they own it all and
then they sell it when it's on top
that's another if you're a banker if
you're you know working at the federal
reserve you're able to predict when
assets are going to be at their highest
and their lowest why wouldn't they take
advantage of that it's natural that they
would so so this is this is not
capitalism this is feudalism 2.0 this is
a new way of enduring and then
indentured servitude that we're all
going through right now whether we like
it or not some people say that might be
a hyperbolic statement but how else
could you explain what's happening right
now in the real world with so much pain
with so much suffering with economic
inequality that's being driven by these
people and then they have the gall to
come out publicly and say corporations
are greedy it's not their fault i just
want i want to mention real quick
in the during the during the november
2020 election cycle we were regularly
hitting over 100 000 concurrent viewers
on this show
now we're getting right now we have
about 41 500 people so it's a lot of
people this is great and you guys rock
my question is those sixty thousand
other people will be watching in real
time where'd they go are they are they
paying attention still
because everybody pays attention when
the election happens
where are you at now because i'm willing
to bet a lot of these people voted for
biden not every person who watches
most of them probably voted for trump to
be honest but i've seen so many people
who have told me
one they vote for biden and two they did
watch at some point during the election
and i'm just like how does that happen
like how do you watch our show and there
are you know a lot of moderate people
watch
well no i just remember this under
obama when i was very you know pro obama
when he was first elected and first of
all i love that the show keeps me
grounded on both the left and the right
because hearing you luke talk about the
corporations i was like got it i'm
pro-gun so i can use it to kill the rich
uh that's not true that's not true i'm
kidding um i
no i think that
i remember everyone voted for obama and
they were like change hope we're set
everything is great and then they just
stopped holding them accountable and
then he just got kind of more
centrist more centrist more centrist the
obamacare wasn't at all there was
nothing like universal healthcare about
it it wasn't socialized medicine it was
you know there was some good stuff but
it was a lot of like corporate
uh
and i think people just they they treat
elections like sports and they're
excited and they're gossipy and they're
watching shows like this because they
feel like they're a part of something
where they can actually make a
difference because one day they go in
and their voice is heard and blah blah
blah and then they just leave because
it's not fun and they don't hold people
they don't want to hold people
accountable because that's where it gets
hard that was the the 2008 election was
the prime example of reality tv meets
political elections i know exactly what
you're talking about people have this
fervent
exuberance for hope and change they
voted for obama obama got in and then
they wanted him to do it that the
president cannot do anything their job
is to make sure it doesn't go crazy they
veto stuff and if we had posed a
revolution against the financial markets
and taken control of our monetary supply
obama would have let it happen yeah he
was the k he wasn't a president that
would have stopped us but he couldn't do
anything on his own yeah he was he they
know where he lives and i think we were
talking about this before we went on air
maybe we were talking about this earlier
tim where it's like the people who voted
for
biden should be oh let's talk about this
with taylor the people who voted for
biden should be the most tuned in should
be the most outraged should be the most
wanting to hold them accountable because
they're like this is our guy this is our
fault we need to keep him in line so i
guess what i was trying to say before is
there's a lot of people who aren't in
politics right now they they come in
and i think it's fairly obvious you know
the 2020 psych was massive it was trump
they come and they hang out they watch
something happens now we're all still
here at the front of the ship but all
those people have walked away in the
lower decks and they're playing you know
they're doing their thing they're
feeling the heat they're feeling the
pain they're watching the ship sink but
we need to get these people back up here
to pay attention and you know be
involved again yeah i think a lot of
people are tired a lot of people are
sick of the lies i think a lot of people
are disillusioned with our current
system because they vote left they think
they're going to get hope and change and
they get drone bombs and domestic spying
100 they vote
right-wing and republican and they're
going to think they're going to have uh
conservative fiscal policies and they
don't they have the same kind of
reckless spending as they did during the
democrats and and then they have the the
trump scene and people are questioning
themselves like what why should i even
be involved in this i got to worry about
myself i got to worry about making ends
meet i got to worry about my future
which again
upward economic mobility is being taken
away from individuals in such a drastic
way people are being looted people are
being gutted their savings are being
obliterated right in front of them
inflation is one of the largest taxes
the government could wage on the public
and they're waging it in such an extreme
way it's absolutely astounding to see
people uh you know
just be able to make ends meet at this
point let me let me tell you if you
didn't know jamie first i'll ask you
some questions okay how's the economy
doing uh pretty bad but pretty bad um
how the american people
faring with these high gas prices you
know what i'm gonna i'm gonna go out and
limit say uh they're not doing great so
the so the us government sent 12 12
million dollars i believe to pakistan
for gender studies programs
[Music]
is gender studies code for gas money for
americans it's not it's it's is it
pakistani for just kidding so but here's
the reason here's i'll give you the
general reason has been that they've
given for doing this yeah is that the us
by giving money away it makes people use
it and retains confidence in the us
dollar
so the idea is let's just give out all
this money around the world then
everyone will be like i got u.s dollars
i can use it
yeah but i think that that's the premise
of modern monetary theory that they're
going to invest in production and what
they're doing is they're putting it in
bank accounts and getting interest so
they're buying crypto and putting it in
panama like
it's not
it's an aberration of what's supposed to
happen i don't think it's that simple
tim i think it's the us government
buying political favors and saying hey
we want this national resource we want
this corporation that we're tied in to
have access to this natural
this product that you have here and and
i think this is why we send speed boats
to sri lanka sri lanka by the way if you
look at what's happening there socially
and politically it should be a warning
for the rest of the world right now you
have people
rioting you have people angry you have
people going hungry and i think that's
going to be happening in a lot of other
places around the world maybe not in the
united states anytime soon but i think
definitely there's going to be a lot of
economic instability in africa and the
middle east coming very soon that's
going to disrupt a lot of normal life
flow for everyone because it's also
going to spur on a migration crisis as
well well i wanted to go back to what
you were talking about luke about why
regular people have stopped paying
attention and i also i was thinking
about it i wonder if it's because we
have become so
such a reality tv show world when it
comes to how we digest our politics that
going after a trump tweet because trump
tweeted something mean is easy
examining why you know i mean i would
like to think i'm fairly informed and i
had to ask all of you guys well what
will we do for gas prices right like
those are complicated issues i mean in
fact it's one of the reasons trump won
right it's he could actually appeal to
everybody you ask a lot of people you
know what do we do for the economy and
then they're like well it's going to
start with election reform and they're
checked out but you just go ah the
mexicans are taking your job you're like
got it that's easy right and so i wonder
if with the biden stuff i think part of
it is they're like my guy won i think
part of it is they're burnt out like you
were alluding to you know i talk to my
friends who have big podcasts and not
the political world but in like
self-development and stuff and they're
just like dude in a couple years people
aren't even good like trump burned
people out you know like all those
tweeters and stuff that now that it's
biden even though the country isn't
doing well
there's nothing
there's no you know big tweets there's
no big you know drama and they just i
think they're just sort of checked out
they're embarrassed too yeah because
it's kind of like you see you can't not
be you see
him communicating and like why would
they want to come out and engage it and
talk about politics when it's like look
what we just did our guy but they knew
this i mean when he was running to be
president of the united states he wasn't
doing rallies he was known as the
basement candidate he was known as just
doing wonky shots from the corporate
media that were incoherent then
people knew what they were getting
themselves based on candidates
though yeah yeah i don't i don't think
people did i i told this to bannon uh
trump was anti-elected people people
were voting against trump not for biden
there's a definitely a feeling that
that's happening on the other side of
the tv screen it's really disturbing
when you realize how connected things
are and that no this is all here with
you right now this is you this is all
coming it's here we are here together
even though there's a screen between us
this is uh
probably also sorry tim it has to with
like why it's 40k versus 100k
has to do with
the algorithms i mean it's like what is
being
promoted
at certain times or or do you do you
truly think no
organic thing i think the crazy thing is
how
right now we talked about talk about it
last week with republicans just
responding to everything democrats say
welcome to our special weekend show
sunday uncensored every week we produce
four uncensored episodes of the tim cast
irl podcast exclusively at timcast.com
and we're going to bring you the most
important for our weekend show if you
want to check out more segments just
like this become a member at timcast.com
now enjoy the show